and if you stay here you're gonna die
too
[Music]
june
boat
now even no no no don't make me leave
you again
that is emmy winner samira wildly with
elizabeth moss in the popular series the
handmaid's tale wiley is co-producing a
new documentary called the gratitude
project that is premiering tonight at a
private event during the tribeca
festival in new york the documentary is
a partnership with a multivitamin brand
one a day it features many stories
including wiley's own about the power of
practicing gratitude in her life
here's a clip
learning to practice gratitude
has been one of the greatest lessons in
his life
it's thanking yourself thanking your
body for allowing you to get out and
have the ability to embrace life i'm
just a woman on fire
gratitude
is self-love
to be able to have self-love in order to
give back to others
samara wiley joins us right now as we
were watching that trailer a big smile
on your face i love your smile i just
have to say why so much why so much joy
when you were watching the trailer of
the gratitude project you know it's been
such a journey for me with this
gratitude project and and loving myself
and loving my body and who i am and
to see that the end product and to see
like where my journey has gone i just
feel really proud of myself and i feel
proud of what um me and one a day are
doing with the with the uh the gratitude
project you mentioned loving yourself
and loving your body you were very open
um and personal in this documentary and
you talked about being in denial about
having diabetes absolutely did you feel
vulnerable but was there healing in that
vulnerability i was i was so mad that i
had this thing that none of my other
siblings had and um so yeah for about 10
years there honestly i lived like i i
nothing was wrong with me and um was
very healing once i was able to look
myself in the face one day and say no
one's going to be able to do this but
you no one's going to be able to take
care of yourself and make this choice
but you and again that's why i had such
a big smile on my face being able to see
the end product
i want to talk about your daughter
because let's do it
she is your gift and i'm sure your
the gratitude you have for her
is incredible
why was it so important for her to be a
part of this this message yeah i mean i
think
what i've learned as a parent is
you have to sometimes teach by example
and by i want to be able to model um
good behavior for her and i feel like
the first step is in in taking care of
myself
is showing her how to love herself and
showing her how to love who she whoever
she turns out to be um and it's that's
been really really important for me
i want to ask you about her name george
elizabeth that's that's queen george
yeah
george
oh you want to i want to know why you
think right right
um i just honestly everyone's always
asked for some story and i wish i had
some awesome great beautiful story to
tell you but i just thought the name was
cute i love it she's going to create one
hell of a story with that name yeah she
is you know one final question on
gratitude because they call it the
practice of gratitude does it take work
is it something you have to do every day
absolutely i think it's something that
you have to make a conscious choice to
make a part of your life um it's you
know something that i think can easily
fall by the wayside because there's so
many things that we have to do every day
um so it's you know
taking the moment to meditate taking the
moment to do yoga to do anything that
that um is for your body that can help
um you just remember
how amazing it is to have a body that
works and all of those things um
it's i forget what the question was
a lot of people are grateful for the
handmaid's team oh yeah oh talk about it
out of their out of their life into a
whole another world
so this season is going to debut in
september i believe i have that right uh
what's next for your character can you
even talk
like i don't even know um
you guys know this come on now i can't
tell you
come on samir give us something well
maura escaped from gillard we we
yes moya escaped from gilead in in
season one and there's um been a journey
um and i can't tell you nothing
does she find happiness um you know what
that's a great question actually i think
that that's a real question in her whole
arc as a character on the show um being
in a place like that with so much trauma
and escaping and now you're a refugee
it's there's so many things to find
happiness there's so many blocks in your
way um
so i think that's actually i really love
that you said that i think that moira's
journey is like a journey to find
happiness now you have said that you
feel it's a responsibility to show young
lgbtq
kids
what's possible why did you feel like
that was your responsibility
um
i think
there were some shoes that were given to
me in the very beginning of my career
that i thought were too big for me
um and i didn't want to step in them i
felt like
this is just too much for me and when i
made the decision to
say no i'm gonna step into this role i'm
gonna i'm gonna make a decision and have
my wife and i be on the cover of martha
martha stewart weddings because we're a
queer couple and i want to show people
what's possible some queer person in the
middle of the country that has never
seen anything like this so
i it's
it it felt like a
maybe a choice to to take this on and
have it be my responsibility but i don't
even feel like it's really a choice i
feel like this is what i'm supposed to
be doing and that choice has given
people strength so we appreciate you
thank you so much for joining us samara
wiley you're the best thank you we'll be
right back samira thank you